Tim you actually went to this lab in
person what did you see that's right I
went out there um well what I can tell
you is actually it's very nondescript
unless you knew it was a lab for Apple
there's no way you would discover it on
your own you know it's a white tarred
lab but previously was owned by Qualcomm
it doesn't really look like much at all
and in fact there's no signage that
really indicates who resides inside it's
only after you go you know across a
driveway up some stairs inside to the
reception where you see the Apple logo
and at that point you realize that
belongs to Apple but even at the
reception desk they they won't talk at
all they Allah basically refused entry
and you'd really need to make an
appointment to go any further they
wouldn't even give out details of who
the person in charge would be or how the
best way to make contact with the
company would be so they're very very
secretive and people are in and around
the facility that I've spoke to or
basically declined to comment they
wouldn't talk about it they said it's
very secret they're not allowed to talk
about it at all and so there's very much
a veil of secrecy around the whole
facility and that's really in keeping
with Apple when they've got these kind
of skunks works projects or these these
secret projects going on everyone shuts
down and keeps it a secret now you
believe that they're working on new
screens inside this lab and the goal of
course is thinner lighter better you
know more energy efficient screens what
do you think is actually happening
inside well the information that I've
received from various sources indicates
that it's it's basically a production
lab they do have production facilities
inside now this is not necessarily for
full-scale mass production but more like
test production because developing a
screen it's a very thin device the
screen itself for an iPhone and the
production process is fundamentally
important to the way the whole thing
puts is put together and so as you
develop the technology developing how to
actually make it is crucially important
and so that's what they're working on
for basically developments on current
level types of screens such as LCD which
is the dominant technology right now
as well as a keen interest that Apple
has in moving into OLED which is a very
different area and that's something that
they are very interested in working on
more